These special episodes of 99% Invisible are brought to you by the Lexus GX and Sirius XM. The new Lexus GX shows how an off-roading, overlanding vehicle can also be a true luxury vehicle. Every GX comes standard with Sirius XM, offering a rich array of music, sports, talk, and news. Huge thanks to the Lexus GX and Sirius XM for making this episode possible. Later, we'll meet up with a special guest, Sirius XM host Rachel Steele, and experience the GX and Sirius XM for making this episode possible. Later, we'll meet up with a special guest, Sirius XM host, Rachel Steele, and experience the GX firsthand. So stay tuned.
欢迎收听由雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 赞助播出的《99% Invisible》特别节目。全新雷克萨斯 GX 展现了越野远行车辆同样可以成为真正的豪华座驾。每一台 GX 都标配 Sirius XM，为您提供丰富多彩的音乐、体育、脱口秀和新闻节目。非常感谢雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 让本期节目得以与大家见面。稍后我们将与特别嘉宾、Sirius XM 主持人雷切尔·斯蒂尔（Rachel Steele）会面，并亲身体验 GX 和 Sirius XM。敬请期待。
To learn more about the GX, visit lexus.com slash GX. And with every purchase, you'll get three months of Sirius XM free. The all new Lexus GX. Live up to it. And now, on with the show. It's 106 miles to it. And now, on with the show. It's 106 miles to Chicago. We've got a full tank of gas, half a bag of popcorn.
要了解有关 GX 的更多信息，请访问 lexus.com/GX。每次购买，您都将免费获得三个月的 Sirius XM 服务。全新雷克萨斯 GX，尽享精彩。接下来，让我们进入正题。距离芝加哥还有 106 英里。我们油箱加满，还有半袋爆米花。
Car snacks. It's dark and we're wearing sunglasses. Hit it. This is 99% invisiblevisible. I'm Roman Mars in Chicago. A few years ago at the start of the pandemic, I wrote an episode where I just simply talked about the design details in my house because I knew we were going to be inside for a while and I thought it was important to find some joy and purpose in that. The episode is called Roman Marsh describes things as they are.
车上零食。天黑了，我们还戴着太阳镜。出发吧。这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars），在芝加哥为您主持。几年前疫情刚开始时，我做过一期节目，简单聊了聊我家里的设计细节，因为我知道我们要待在室内一段时间，而且我觉得在其中找到一些快乐和意义很重要。那期节目叫做《罗曼·马斯如实描述事物》。
You should check it out. It is a real time capsule and often cited as one of our best episodes. Well since then, I wanted to record a companion episode of me free from my house, out in the world, narrating what I see the way that, you know, years of hosting 99% invisible has trained me to see. So over the next couple of months, we're going into three cities that shaped who I am and how I think about design. These bonus episodes are made possible by the new 2024, Lexus GX and Sirius XM, who
大家应该去听听看。它真的是一个时代胶囊，经常被认为是我们最好的节目之一。自那以后，我一直想录制一期姊妹篇节目，讲述我走出家门、身处广阔世界中，用多年主持《99% Invisible》所训练出的视角去观察和讲述我所看到的一切。所以在接下来的几个月里，我们将走进三座塑造了我和我的设计思维的城市。这些特别版节目由全新 2024 款雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 鼎力支持，他们
heard this idea and said, we're totally in. Just go make something cool. And so for me, the only place I could start was the city of Chicago. I took my longtime partner and new wife, Joy, so that I could have someone to tell stories to. Do you want to give your imitation of what it's like to walk around with me?
听到这个想法后说，我们完全赞同。尽管去做出酷炫的作品吧。所以对我来说，唯一能开始的地方就是芝加哥。我带上了我多年的伴侣、新婚妻子乔伊（Joy），这样我就能有个听我讲故事的人了。你想不想模仿一下和我一起走路是什么感觉？
Sure. Let me tell you about this roof. Let me tell you about this curb cut. It's a delight. I don't know how I became Yogi Bear in your mind. Chicago is a design lover's paradise. So much thought has gone into every little aspect of the city, starting with the street grid itself.
当然。让我跟你讲讲这个屋顶。让我跟你讲讲这个缘石坡道。这太令人愉快了。我不知道我在你心目中怎么就变成瑜伽熊了。芝加哥是设计爱好者的天堂。这座城市的每一个小细节都倾注了无数的心血，首先就是它的街道网格本身。
So in 1830, before Chicago even existed, the state of Illinois decided to lay out plots along the Chicago River to sell in order to help pay for the canal that was going to connect Lake Michigan to the Mississippi. So Surveyor James Thompson drew the first plat. That's what it's called. It's called a plat. I like the flat-a's kind of make me giggle. Plat. And that plat was the foundation of how Chicago streets are laid out today. So he drew straight streets uniformly 66 feet wide, which was actually
所以在 1830 年，在芝加哥甚至还不存在之前，伊利诺伊州决定沿着芝加哥河规划地块并进行售卖，以此来帮助筹集资金修建运河，将密歇根湖与密西西比河连接起来。因此，测量员詹姆斯·汤普森（James Thompson）绘制了第一张地块图。就是这样，这叫地块图（plat）。我喜欢这个发音，带有平平的“a”音，总让我咯咯发笑。地块图（plat）。而这张地块图就是今天芝加哥街道布局的基础。因此，他画出了笔直的街道，宽度统一为 66 英尺，这实际上是
the full length of a surveyors chain. So he just kind of like as big as possible. And then alleys are 16 feet wide by secting each block and any building that was already there that was already built that was in the way of his streets, they were forced to move to fit on the grid, which wasn't that big of a deal in 1830 because only like 300 people lived in Chicago at the time or pre-Chicago at the time. In 10 years, it would be 10 times that in Chicago at the time or pre-Chicago at the time. In ten years, it would be ten times that in Chicago. That original plat was only a half a mile in area, but over two centuries, Chicago grew in exactly the way Thompson laid out that uniform regular spacing and it eventually
测量员链的满长度。所以他当时的想法差不多就是“建得越大越好”。然后巷子的宽度是 16 英尺，横贯每一个街区；任何已经存在、已经建好且挡住他规划街道的建筑物，都被迫搬迁以契合网格。这在 1830 年并不是什么大问题，因为当时芝加哥或者说前芝加哥地区只住了大约 300 人。而在十年后，这个数字将翻十倍。而在十年后，芝加哥的人口将是这个数字的十倍。最初的地块图面积只有半平方英里，但在两个世纪里，芝加哥完全按照汤普森规划的那种整齐划一的间距发展，最终
encompassed over 230 square miles. It's as close as any city is to a true mathematical grid. The reason I'm telling you this right here on the corner of state and Madison is because this is the zero, zero point of that perfect grid. So the zero, zero point was picked in 1901 and this is when the real power of the grid comes into
其面积扩展到了 230 多平方英里。这是任何城市中最接近真正数学网格的存在。我之所以在州街（State）和麦迪逊街（Madison）的这个路口告诉你这些，是因为这里就是那个完美网格的零点零坐标。所以零点零坐标是在 1901 年选定的，正是在这个时候，网格真正的威力开始
full effect. And this is the Brennan plan. Tell me more. Tell me more about the Brennan plan. So Chicago had grown so much between 1830 and 1900. They were annexing all these adjacent communities and they were all snapping into the grid. But the street names and addresses were all a big old mess because other towns had, you know, Chicago Avenue here and Madison here
全面显现。这就是布伦南规划（Brennan Plan）。多讲讲。多讲讲布伦南规划。所以芝加哥在 1830 年到 1900 年间发展得太快了。他们吞并了所有这些邻近的社区，而这些社区全部都硬套进了网格中。但是街道名称和地址却成了一团大乱麻，因为其他城镇有各自的命名，你知道的，这里有芝加哥大街，那里有麦迪逊街
and Michigan here and they were all duplicated and messy and the numbers were messy, just sort of, you know, chaotic. Okay, so a private citizen named Edward Brennan approached Approach City Council with a plan where the street numbers would locate properties relative to a central X axis, like an east-west axis, and a north-south Y axis. And the imaginary zero-zero center of the point being this intersection of Madison State and we're in the loop downtown.
还有密歇根街，全都是重复的，乱七八糟的，门牌号也很乱，总之就是各种（你懂的）混乱。好吧，于是有个叫爱德华·布伦南（Edward Brennan）的普通市民，他向市议会提出了一项规划，通过该规划，街道门牌号可以根据一个中央 X 轴（也就是东西轴线）和一个南北 Y 轴来定位物业，而虚构的零点零坐标中心就是麦迪逊街和州街的这个十字路口，也就是我们在市中心的“环线”（Loop）。
Okay, so, and once you understand this system, the address will tell you where you are relative to this point Like which side of the street you're on the streets even have Those coordinates like on the street signs themselves So like Fullerton Street is an east-west street that when you're there you're 2400 north of this point You know like it's just it's a lot. It's hard to explain. Yeah You have to kind of experience it but just know that it works and it is really cool And once you get to know it, you'll never be lost in Chicago. Okay, you know how much I love the Chicago flag, right?
好的，一旦你理解了这个系统，地址就会告诉你你相对于这个点的位置，比如你在街道的哪一侧。街道甚至还有这些坐标，就印在路牌本身上。比如富勒顿街（Fullerton Street）是一条东西向的街道，当你身处那里时，你就在这个点以北 2400 个单位的地方。你知道的，这东西挺复杂的。很难解释清楚。是的，你得亲身体验一下，但只要知道它管用就行，而且真的很酷。一旦你熟悉了它，你在芝加哥就永远不会迷路。好吧，你知道我有多喜欢芝加哥市旗吗？
I do It has a beautiful flag. It's a beautiful flag. Do you remember what it looks like? Yeah, okay There are two fields of light blue. The field is the back. The field is the sort of, so there's white field. White field, there are two blue stripes. Yes.
我知道。它有一面漂亮的旗子。这是一面漂亮的旗子。你还记得它长什么样吗？对，好吧，有两个浅蓝色的区块。这个区块是背景。这个区块是那种……所以有一个白色区块。白色区块，有两条蓝色条纹。是的。
Light blue. Horizontal stripes representing the Chicago River and Lake Michigan. And we have some red stars. Yeah, how many? Ah! Four? Yes, four six-pointed red stars across the middle.
浅蓝色。代表芝加哥河和密歇根湖的水平条纹。我们还有一些红星。是的，几颗？啊！四颗？是的，中间有四颗六角红星。
And the four stars represent different pivotal moments in Chicago's history. So one of them is the founding of Fort Dearborn, which preceded Chicago. One of them is the great Chicago Fire. One of them is the Columbian Exposition, which is the white city. And the last one is the Century of Progress exhibition. So I think this flag is perfect and probably shouldn't change, but I would consider adding one star
这四星代表了芝加哥历史上的不同关键时刻。其中一颗是先于芝加哥建立的迪尔伯恩堡（Fort Dearborn）。其中一颗是芝加哥大火。其中一颗是世博会（Columbian Exposition），也就是“白城”。最后一颗是“世纪进步”博览会（Century of Progress exhibition）。所以我觉得这面旗子堪称完美，可能不应该改变，但我会考虑再加一颗星
for the Thompson Plan that made the grid and one star for the Brennan Plan. That's how important I think it is. That's how critical I think it is to, you know, what makes Chicago, Chicago. It's certainly more important than the Century of Progress exhibition. It's more flag worthy. It's more flag worthy than that.
用来表彰奠定网格的汤普森规划，再加一颗星表彰布伦南规划。我觉得它就是这么重要。我觉得它对于造就了今日之芝加哥的事物来说，是具有决定性意义的。它当然比“世纪进步”博览会更重要。它更当得起旗帜的象征。比起那个，它更配被印在旗子上。
You know what I'm saying? Okay, anyway. Okay, so while we're in this kind of area, we're about a 10 minute walk from one of my favorite buildings. And you're going to hear me say that a lot, that this is my favorite building. And every time I'm sincere. Okay, so let's fast forward there. All right, so the name of the building
你知道我在说什么吗？好吧，无论如何。好吧，既然我们在这一带，我们距离我最喜欢的一栋建筑大约只有 10 分钟的步行路程。你会听到我经常这么说，说这就是我最喜欢的建筑。而且每次我都是真心的。好吧，那我们就快进到那里吧。好的，这座建筑的名字
is actually on the building. It's the Manadnok building, which is a great Manadnok building. It's a great name. It was constructed in 1891. It's 16 stories high. OK, and so I want you to, I'm not trying to quiz you, but I want you to tell me what you see when you see this building,
其实就写在建筑上。它是莫纳德诺克大厦（Monadnock Building），一个很棒的莫纳德诺克大厦。名字真棒。它建于 1891 年。有 16 层高。好的，我想让你……我不是在考你，但我想让你告诉我，当你看到这座建筑时，你看到了什么，
like what are some of its characteristics. Okay, well it's massive, but not in the same way, like super tall like these other skyscrapers. Yeah, it feels heavy. But yes, it feels heavy, dense. It is heavy, it's very heavy. That was one of its problems.
比如它有哪些特征。嗯，它很宏伟，但不是那种形式的宏伟，不像其他摩天大楼那样超高。是的，它感觉很沉重。但是是的，它感觉很沉重、厚实。它是很沉重，非常重。这是它过去的问题之一。
It was like, it was sinking for a while and they had to shore it up. It's very heavy. That was one of its problems. It was like it was sinking for a while and they had to shore it up. It was it's so heavy. What is it made out of? It's a dark brown brick. Yeah. So this is, that's the first key thing to it. This is the tallest masonry skyscraper in the world. So it is completely made of brick, at least well the north half of it is. And those bricks are the reason why it's so heavy. So like if you could imagine like this thing was built the real old-fashioned way like a pyramid you know a brick on top of a brick on top of a brick that's why it's so heavy that's's why, and it's really significant
它曾一度在下沉，他们不得不对其进行加固。它非常重。这是它过去的问题之一。它曾一度在下沉，他们不得不对其进行加固。它……它太重了。它是用什么建造的？是深棕色的砖。是的。所以，这是它的第一个关键之处。这是世界上最高的砖石结构摩天大楼。所以它完全是用砖建造的，至少北半部分是这样的。而那些砖就是它如此沉重的原因。所以，如果你能想象的话，这东西是用非常老式的方法建造的，就像金字塔一样，你知道的，砖压着砖，砖叠着砖，这就是它为什么这么重，这也是为什么……而且它非常重要，
for being a very big masonry skyscraper. So the other thing you notice, the consequence of this brick construction, you notice how it's flared at the base and curves inward as it goes up. You know what I'm saying? If you look through the display window at the hat shop, you'll see that the walls are super thick.
因为它是一座非常宏伟的砖石摩天大楼。所以你注意到的另一件事，这种砖石建筑带来的结果，你注意到它的基座是外扩的，随着高度上升向内收窄吗？你知道我在说什么吗？如果你透过帽店的展示橱窗看进去，你会发现墙壁超级厚。
Like that's not just like a frame. That's like actually the wall. It has to be that thick. It's about, it's'll see that the walls are super thick. Like that's not just like a frame. That's like actually the wall. It has to be that thick. It's about, it's about six feet wide at the base and about 18 inches wide at the top. And this is all because, you know, for it to have, yeah, that's bigger than your arms and then, and then little tiny. And so this is necessary because all the weight of the upper floors have to be like held by the bricks at the bottom.
那不仅仅是一个框架。那真的就是墙。它必须得那么厚。它大约是……你会发现墙壁超级厚。那不仅仅是一个框架。那真的就是墙。它必须得那么厚。它大约是……基座宽约 6 英尺，顶部宽约 18 英寸。这一切都是因为，你知道的，为了让它拥有……是的，这比你的手臂还要粗，然后呢……然后又变得很小。所以这是必要的，因为高层所有的重量都必须由底部的砖块来支撑。
And so they have to be super wide to sort of to support everything up above. And it makes it like kind of like a pyramid. I mean, not, you know, not, it's obviously not as dramatic and only swings out a little bit. But if it wasn't for steel frame construction, all buildings would be pyramids if they got tall enough.
因此它们必须超级宽，以便支撑上方的一切。这让它看起来有点像金字塔。我是说，不是……你知道的，当然没有那么戏剧化，而且向外扩展的幅度也只是一点点。但如果不是因为有了钢框架结构，如果建筑物建得足够高，所有的建筑都会变成金字塔。
Because what you mostly see when you see bricks on the surface of buildings are not structural bricks. They're like skin. They're like there's a steel frame and they put bricks over it to make it look like a brick building, but it's not made of bricks inside. So actually the southern half of this building
因为当你看到建筑表面有砖块时，你 meistens 看到的往往不是结构砖。它们就像是一层皮肤。就好像里面有一个钢框架，然后在外面贴上砖，让它看起来像是一座砖砌建筑，但它内部并不是用砖砌成的。事实上，这座建筑的南半部分
has some modern construction with some frames in it, but this part is completely masonry. And that's why it is so weird and kind of that heaviness you feel it, you know, it's kind of cool but it's because of the way it was built. It's also like really dark brick which is right. It's just like a choice. So I want to get to two other buildings that are my favorite buildings and they're just north of the river which which is not too far from here. But on the way there, I want to check out the sign on the Chicago theater. OK, on the marquee behind the middle sea of the word Chicago, OK,
采用了一些带有框架的现代施工工艺，但这一部分完全是砖石结构。这就是为什么它显得如此怪异，而且你能感受到那种沉重感，你知道的，这其实挺酷的，但这是由它的建造方式决定的。而且它用的也是那种真的很深的砖，这很对。这纯粹是一种选择。所以我想去看看另外两座也是我最喜欢的建筑，它们就在河的北面，离这里不太远。但在去的路上，我想去看看芝加哥剧院（Chicago Theater）上的招牌。好的，在“Chicago”这个词中间的下方标志牌上，
is a Y shaped symbol. You can kind of miss it, but it's this Y shaped symbol. And this is what's called the Municipal Device of Chicago. It's a simplified map of Chicago that shows the river splitting into the north and south branches. That's what the Y comes from. Since 1917, this has been the official symbol of the city, and it's been used on official buildings and on city vehicles and stuff like that.
有一个 Y 形符号。你可能会错过它，但确实有这个 Y 形符号。这就是所谓的芝加哥市徽（Municipal Device of Chicago）。它是芝加哥的简化地图，显示了河流分叉为南北两支。Y 字就来源于此。自 1917 年以来，这就成为了该市的官方标志，并被用在官方建筑、城市车辆等上面。
I noticed it a lot on control boxes and like the gates of parks and stuff like that. You'll see a Y there and that means Chicago. It was used a lot in the beginning of the 20th century, less so later on. You wouldn't see it as much as the city of Chicago flag, like around the city, but you'll find Ys everywhere. And so it's kind of fun to do a little scavenger hunt
我在控制箱、公园大门之类的东西上经常注意到它。你会看到那里有一个 Y，这就代表芝加哥。它在 20世纪初被广泛使用，后来就没那么常见了。你在城市里不会像看到芝加哥市旗那样频繁地看到它，但到处都能找到 Y 形符号。所以，到处寻找
for why is around and so we should do that while we're here. You like a scavenger hunt? I do love a good scavenger hunt. I mean because life moves pretty fast and if you don't stop and look around once in a while you could miss it. So this gorgeous thing right here is the Wrigley building and it is so fancy. It is covered in white terracotta, is that great silver skybridge in the middle, which I really love that thing actually. And what I can't get over when it comes to this thing is that this was all bought and paid for with chewing gum money. It was designed as the Wrigley headquarters construction started in 1920. Wrigley was kind of late to the chewing gum game.
Y 形符号其实就像是一场小型寻宝游戏，我们在这里的时候也应该玩一玩。你喜欢寻宝游戏吗？我确实很喜欢好玩的寻宝游戏。我是说，因为生活节奏太快了，如果你不偶尔停下来环顾四周，你可能会错过它。所以眼前这个华丽的建筑就是箭牌大厦（Wrigley Building），它太豪华了。它贴满了白色的陶瓦，中间还有那个很棒的银色空中连廊，我其实非常喜欢那个设计。而且关于这个建筑，我最百思不得其解的是，这一切都是用口香糖赚来的钱买下的。它被设计为箭牌公司的总部，始建于 1920 年。箭牌（Wrigley）当时算是个口香糖行业的后起之秀。
He was the serial entrepreneur, so he sold soap. And as a promotion, he would give away baking powder with the purchase of the soap. And then it turned out that the baking powder was more popular than the soap, so he started selling the baking powder. And then as a promotion for the baking powder, he started giving away sticks of chewing gum instead of baking powder. And then he learned that the sticks of chewing gum were more popular than the baking powder, and so he just started selling chewing gum from there.
他是个连续创业者，所以他卖过肥皂。作为促销手段，他会在购买肥皂时赠送发酵粉。结果证明，发酵粉比肥皂更受欢迎，于是他开始卖发酵粉。然后作为发酵粉的促销手段，他开始赠送口香糖条，而不是发酵粉。接着他了解到口香糖条比发酵粉更受欢迎，于是他干脆从那时起开始出售口香糖。
When he found chewing gum, that he found his true calling, and it paid for this building, it paid for like Wrigley Field is named after Wrigley. I just find that so kind of amazing how much people spent on chewing gum. Turn of the center. I sure did.
当他发现了口香糖时，他找到了真正的使命，这笔钱买下了这栋建筑，买下了……就像箭牌球场（Wrigley Field）就是以箭牌命名的。我只是觉得这太神奇了，人们竟然在口香糖上花了这么多钱。转到中心去。我当然花过。
I'm sure did. Okay, so are you tired? You wanna give up? Are you thirsty for more? I'm thirsty for did. Okay, so are you tired? You want to give up? Are you thirsty for more? I'm thirsty for more. Okay. Okay, so then let's turn over here and cross the street. This is one of my favorite buildings.
我当然花过。好吧，那你累了吗？你想放弃吗？还是你还想看更多？我渴望了解……好吧。好吧，那我们转过这里过马路吧。这是我最喜欢的建筑之一。
This is the Tribune Tower. And when I lived here, it was home of the Chicago Tribune now it's the private apartments actually that's kind of surprised me until I was doing some research before. This building is the result of a design competition that was held in 1922 it's this sort of neogothic vertical lined skyscraper on the bottom and it has this like gothic cathedral hat on its head. Yeah, yeah, there's a lot going on up there. There's a lot.
这就是论坛报大厦（Tribune Tower）。当我住在这里时，它是《芝加哥论坛报》的总部，而现在它其实成了私人公寓，这让我有点惊讶，直到我之前做了一些研究。这座建筑是 1922 年举办的一场设计竞赛的产物，它的底部是那种新哥特式垂直线条的摩天大楼，顶部则戴着一顶类似哥特式大教堂的帽子。对，对，上面有很多细节。有很多细节。
It even has flying buttresses up there on the top. On a real cathedral, those buttresses would hold up the walls, but here they don't do anything. They're just there to look like a cathedral buttress. They're kind of silly. They're just decorative. It is this extremely weird monstrosity of a building. Like I don't know, like I kind of like it.
它甚至在顶部有飞扶壁。在真正的教堂里，这些扶壁用来支撑墙壁，但在这里它们没有任何作用。它们存在只是为了看起来像教堂的扶壁。它们有点傻，纯粹是装饰。这是一座极其诡异的怪物般的大楼。怎么说呢，我其实还挺喜欢它的。
I don't know. I like it too. I mean I kind of like it, but like its problem was that when this design competition was happening modernism was just getting going really. And skyscraper architecture was celebrating clean lines and simplicity. And then this design won the contest and the sort of forward thinking critics just hated it. But, you know, I think it's all right.
我也说不上来。我也挺喜欢的。我是说我挺喜欢的，但它当时的问题是，在这个设计竞赛举行时，现代主义才刚真正兴起。而摩天大楼建筑当时崇尚的是干净的线条和简洁性。然后这个设计赢了比赛，那些具有前瞻性的评论家们简直恨透了它。不过，你知道，我觉得它挺不错的。
I think it's interesting, you know, at least. Now what's really cool is the building that isn't here. The second place finisher of this design competition from the Chicago Tribune Architecture Contest was a design by Alial Saranen. He was this Finnish architect and he's the father of Eero Saranen who became one of the most important architects of the 20th century. So Alial Saranen's Tribune Tower design, it won $20,000 as a second-placed finisher.
我觉得它至少很有趣。现在最酷的是那座不在这里的建筑。芝加哥论坛报建筑竞赛的第二名是埃利尔·沙里宁（Alial Saranen）的设计。他是这位芬兰建筑师，也是埃罗·沙里宁（Eero Saranen）的父亲，后者成为了20世纪最重要的建筑师之一。所以埃利尔·沙里宁的论坛报大楼设计作为第二名赢得了2万美元奖金。
It was never built, but the design was shared with the public and those critics who hated the winning design, they flipped for this tower, the Saranen's Tower. It was the soaring setback tower, had these strong vertical lines. It had a huge effect on 20th century architecture. It influenced a bunch of skyscrapers all over the country. And it's probably the most important silver medalists ever next to Nancy Kerrigan. So that was the first silver medalist I can think of. But Sarenin's design was way more important
它从未被建造，但设计向公众公开了，那些讨厌获胜设计的评论家们对这座沙里宁的大楼赞不绝口。这是一座高耸的退台式大楼，有着强烈的垂直线条。它对20世纪的建筑产生了巨大的影响。它影响了全国各地的一批摩天大楼。它可能是南希·克里根（Nancy Kerrigan）之后最重要的银牌得主了。这是我想到的第一个银牌得主。但沙里宁的设计要重要得多
than this building, even though this building got built. It has way more effect in the world. I find that really fascinating. But the best thing about this weird goth building that actually got built is not the architecture itself, but the architecture embedded on the side of it, which we have to get up close to see. So all along the first floor of the Tribune Tower, you'll see these like little bits and bricks and fragments of other buildings from around the world. Like it's this little
比这座建筑更重要，尽管这座建筑被建成了。它对世界产生了更大的影响。我觉得这真的令人着迷。但这座实际上建成的怪异哥特式建筑最好的地方不是建筑本身，而是嵌入它侧面的建筑碎片，我们必须凑近才能看到。所以在论坛报大楼的一楼，你会看到来自世界各地其他建筑的小块、砖块和碎片。就像是一个
museum just on the street here. So when Colonel McCormick was the publisher of the Tribune in the 1920s. He encouraged his foreign correspondence, I guess you could say, generously to collect artifacts from around the world. He asked to steal them and bring them back. He had a nice little collection. Some people sent them, like, so would there be demolitions or, you know, like extensive rehabs of historical places? Knowing that McCormack, you know, collected these, they would send them to him. So some of them were probably gotten, you know,
街头的小博物馆。所以当麦考密克上校（Colonel McCormick）在20世纪20年代担任《论坛报》出版商时。我猜你可以慷慨地说，他鼓励他的驻外记者收集来自世界各地的文物。他要求他们去偷并带回来。他有一个不错的小收藏。有些人会把它们寄过来，比如，当有历史建筑被拆除或进行大规模整修时？知道麦考密克收集这些东西，他们就会把它们寄给他。所以其中一些可能是通过，你知道的，
above board, but I think they were mostly stolen. Okay, so they had this collection. And so when the building was finished in 1925, they embedded them in the facade with plaques indicating, you know, what they were called and their place of origin. And it's been added to over the decades as well. So if you walk around there you can see pieces of really amazing sights. So like... The Taj Mahal, the Alamo, the Great Pyramid, and the Great Wall of China up there.
正当渠道获得的，但我认为大部分都是偷来的。好吧，他们有了这个收藏。所以当这座建筑在1925年完工时，他们将这些碎片嵌入了外墙，并配有说明其名称和原产地的铭牌。几十年来，这个收藏一直在增加。所以如果你在那里走走，你可以看到真正令人惊叹的名胜古迹的碎片。比如……泰姬陵、阿拉莫、大金字塔和那边的万里长城。
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's one of those ones that wasn't taken with anyone's knowledge. The Great Pyramid, and the Great Wall of China up there. Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's one of those ones that wasn't taken with anyone's knowledge. There's the Berlin Wall here too. And then around the corner here, this is the one that always struck me, is that there's even like a twisted piece of metal from the World Trade Center Towers, which I really kind of, it kind of surprised me and I find it notable and interesting. It's sort of behind the scaffolding there, but it's really different than all the other pieces.
是的，我很确定那是其中一件在不知情的情况下被拿走的。大金字塔和那边的万里长城。是的，我很确定那是其中一件在不知情的情况下被拿走的。这里还有柏林墙。然后在这个拐角处，这个最让我印象深刻，甚至还有世界贸易中心双子塔的一块扭曲的金属，这真的让我有点惊讶，我觉得它很显眼且有趣。它有点在脚手架后面，但它和所有其他碎片真的很不一样。
Most of the pieces are pieces of stone and cornices and this is the piece of metal. So this next thing isn't specific to Chicago, so you can appreciate this whatever city you're in, but it's a very big feature, I think, in Chicago. and that's all the revolving doors. Did you notice all the revolving doors? I did. Yeah, so like everything has a revolving door. Yeah. The revolving door is really important to Chicago because of all the extreme weather, but they were introduced to America from Germany by theophilus van Kennell in the late 1800s and he started this revolving door company and it advertised the doors as they cannot be left open, blown open or slammed. They're always closed yet
大部分碎片都是石头和飞檐，而这是一块金属。所以接下来这个并不是芝加哥特有的，无论你在哪个城市都能体会到这一点，但我认为这是芝加哥的一个非常大的特色，那就是所有的旋转门。你注意到所有的旋转门了吗？我注意到了。是的，所以就像每样东西都有旋转门。是的。旋转门对芝加哥非常重要，因为这里极端的天气，但它们是在19世纪末由狄奥菲勒斯·范·肯内尔（Theophilus van Kennell）从德国引入美国的，他创办了一家旋转门公司，广告宣传这些门说它们不会被开着、被风吹开或被猛关。它们总是关着的，同时
allowing the passage of persons. In other words, they're always open, always closed which is a big deal in a city like Chicago with its extreme weather. So every time a conventional swinging door is opened, the HVAC system has to compensate and that wastes thousands of dollars of energy costs per year. So there are lots of revolving doors here, but here's the thing. I mean how do you feel about using revolving doors? I find them difficult. Yes, so most people do. This is normal. Okay. I thought it was just me. No. No. No. So for safety reasons, there's always a conventional door beside revolving doors. And most people don't really like revolving doors all that much because they feel claustrophobic, they feel weird. You know, it's just one of those
允许人员通行。换句话说，它们总是开着，又总是关着的，这对于像芝加哥这样天气极端的城市来说是一件大事。所以每次传统的平开门被打开时，暖通空调系统都必须进行补偿，这每年浪费数千美元的能源成本。所以这里有很多旋转门，但问题是。我是说你对使用旋转门有什么感觉？我觉得它们很难用。是的，所以大多数人都有同感。这很正常。好吧。我还以为只有我这样。不。不。不。所以出于安全原因，旋转门旁边总是有一个传统的门。大多数人其实并不是那么喜欢旋转门，因为它们让人感到幽闭恐惧，感觉怪怪的。你知道，这只是其中一件
things. So buildings use a lot of signage to kind of nudge people into using the revolving door. And at fancy buildings, the doorman will like start it swinging, you know? Right. Like give it a little nudge or push. Exactly, so that you jump into it rather than, they don't put a person usually on the swinging door.
事情。所以建筑物使用大量的标牌来引导人们使用旋转门。在高档建筑中，门童会开始推动它旋转，你知道的？对。就像给它一个小推力或推一把。没错，这样你就会直接走进旋转门，而不是，他们通常不会在平开门旁安排一个人。
You have to do that one yourself. But if you followed the doorman's suggestion, you'll go through the revolving door. So revolving doors are really great. They're there for a reason. And you should try to use them in terms of like energy usage if you can. But it's totally normal that if you feel like,
那个你得自己推。但如果你听从门童的建议，你就会穿过旋转门。所以旋转门真的很棒。它们存在是有原因的。如果可以的话，为了节能，你应该尽量使用它们。但如果你觉得，
that's uncomfortable. The other way they try to make them better is as they got bigger, they're kind of less claustrophobic. But older buildings, like a lot of them around here are still like little revolving doors Which feel uncomfortable So I want to Show you one thing that's significant
这很不舒服，这也是完全正常的。他们试图让它们变得更好的另一种方法是，随着它们变得更大，幽闭恐惧感会减少。但老旧建筑，比如这里的许多建筑，仍然是那种让人感觉不舒服的小旋转门。所以我想向你展示一件意义重大
But maybe a little more abstract that I point to why I think Chicago is this paragon of design But I want to cross over here because there's a lot of cops There's a lot of cops in Chicago actually. And I'm unpopular with the Chicago Police Department. Why are you so unpopular with the Chicago Police Department? So that building standing alone near Navy Pier, that's Navy Pier, like extending out into the lake. That building, that tall building, is Lake Point Tower. And if you notice, it is the only skyscraper east of Lakeshore Drive.
但可能有点抽象的事情，它说明了为什么我认为芝加哥是设计典范。但我想走到这边来，因为有很多警察。芝加哥其实有很多警察。而且我在芝加哥警察局很不受欢迎。为什么你在芝加哥警察局这么不受欢迎？所以那栋孤立地矗立在海军码头附近的建筑，那就是海军码头，延伸到湖里。那栋高楼，就是点湖大楼（Lake Point Tower）。如果你注意的话，它是湖滨大道（Lakeshore Drive）以东唯一的摩天大楼。
It's doing its own thing. It is. And Lakeshore Drive is this big parkway that runs along Lake Michigan. There was already a city ordinance that limited construction east of Lake Short Drive, but this building kind of snuck in through a loophole. Luckily it's a pretty nice building. That loophole was definitively closed in 1971 with the Lakefront Protection Ordinance, which banned all commercial construction by the lake.
它走着自己的路。确实如此。湖滨大道是沿着密歇根湖延伸的一条大型景观大道。当时已经有一项城市条例限制在湖滨大道以东进行建设，但这栋建筑通过一个漏洞溜了进去。幸运的是，这是一栋相当不错的建筑。这个漏洞在1971年随着《湖滨保护条例》的颁布而被彻底堵上了，该条例禁止了湖畔的所有商业建设。
When I lived here, Chicago Tribune columnist, Eric Zorn, made a list of all the best architectural features in Chicago, and he cited the lakefront ordinance as one of the top pieces of, quote, unquote, architecture in Chicago, which was such a cool idea to me. The lakefront didn't get cluttered up and cut off from the average person
我住在这里时，《芝加哥论坛报》专栏作家埃里克·佐恩（Eric Zorn）列出了芝加哥所有最好的建筑特色，他将湖滨条例列为芝加哥顶级“建筑”之一，这对我来说真是一个很酷的想法。湖滨没有变得杂乱无章，也没有被密集的滨水高楼或码头群与普通人隔离开来
with this dense cluster of waterfront towers or docks. And that insight about what made Chicago so good kind of blew my mind. Like he, it sort of made me think about cities in a totally different way. This place is known as the epicenter of skyscraper design for the 20th century. And the buildings of course have a lot to do with it.
这种关于是什么让芝加哥如此美好的见解让我大开眼界。就像他，这让我以一种完全不同的方式思考城市。这个地方被称为20世纪摩天大楼设计中心。当然，建筑在其中起很大作用。
But I also think it's kind of how the whole city works together, that it's key architectural strength, like the space and the vistas and the vantage points make observing and appreciating the architecture all the better. Like New York has amazing built-ins. I know you love New York. I'm not competing, like there's no competition between better. New York has amazing buildings. I know you love New York. I'm not competing. There's no competition between Chicago and New York.
但我还认为，这在某种程度上取决于整个城市是如何协同运作的，这是其关键的建筑优势，比如空间、景观和观赏点，使得观察和欣赏建筑变得更加美好。就像纽约有惊人的内置建筑。我知道你喜欢纽约。我不是在争论，这之间没有更好的竞争。纽约有惊人的建筑。我知道你喜欢纽约。我不是在竞争。芝加哥和纽约之间没有竞争。
It has amazing buildings, but they're all kind of crammed in on narrow streets, and I appreciate that density. It works really well for New York, but you could be walking along, and all of a sudden the Chrysler building's in front of you, and I could miss it. You know what I mean?
它有令人惊叹的建筑，但它们都挤在狭窄的街道上，我欣赏这种密度。这非常适合纽约，但你走着走着，克莱斯勒大厦突然出现在你面前，而我可能会错过它。你知道我的意思吗？
It's kind of a strange thing, and it could really surprise you. But all these ordinances and conventions and respect for the whole somehow elevates Chicago. Like the buildings talk to each other. As Guy Scraper from the 1990s will borrow and modify a motif from a neighboring building that was erected like 70 years before,
这有点奇怪，它真的会让你感到惊讶。但所有这些条例、惯例和对整体的尊重不知何故提升了芝加哥。就像这些建筑在彼此对话。就像90年代的盖伊·斯克雷珀（Guy Scraper）会借鉴并修改大约70年前建造的邻近建筑的主题一样，
the NBC building has buttresses on it because it's right next to the Chicago Tribune. So the Tribune Tower had buttresses at the top that did nothing. The NBC building has buttresses that actually do something, but they're there because of the other buttresses. And having that space across the river allows for that cross-generational conversation. And it's just made possible because of the simple fact that we can see it all together, that architects really cared how everything looked and worked together. And that's why Chicago, to me, is a city like no other.
NBC大楼上有飞扶壁，因为它紧挨着芝加哥论坛报。所以论坛报大楼顶部有不起作用的飞扶壁。NBC大楼上有实际起作用的飞扶壁，但它们的存在是因为其他飞扶壁。跨越河流拥有这样的空间使得这种跨代对话成为可能。而这仅仅是因为一个简单的客观事实：我们能把这一切尽收眼底，建筑师们真正关心一切是如何看起来和协同工作的。这就是为什么在我看来，芝加哥是一座无与伦比的城市。
And things like the lakefront ordinance are a part of that. It's like a respect for taking in the hole and having this cohesive city in terms of its architecture and design. So this is like the exception that proves the rule. This like building standing outside of the normal rules. But luckily again, it's a pretty good looking building. Sounds like that deserves a star on the flag.
像湖滨条例这样的事情就是其中的一部分。这就像是对欣赏整体以及在建筑和设计方面拥有一个内聚城市的尊重。所以这就像是证明规则的例外。这座大楼就像是打破了常规。但幸运的是，这也是一栋外观相当不错的建筑。听起来这应该在国旗上赢得一颗星。
The lakefront ordinance does. For sure, I think so too. OK, so I want to go to our last stop. We're already at our last stop. I want to take us to my favorite building. No, your favorite building. And it's kind of the building that kind of started it all for me. But to get there, we have to go the Chicago way.
湖滨条例确实如此。当然，我也这么认为。好的，我想去我们的最后一站。我们已经到了最后一站。我想带我去我最喜欢的建筑。不，是你最喜欢的建筑。这有点像是为我开启这一切的建筑。但要到那里，我们必须走“芝加哥的方式”。
What's the Chicago way? They pull a knife, you pull a gun. He sends one to yours at the hospital, you send one to his to the morgue. That's the Chicago Way. But in this specific case, I mean taking Chicago Avenue West to where it meets the north branch of the river. We'll get there after the break.
什么是“芝加哥的方式”？他们拔刀，你拔枪。他送你的人去医院，你送他的人去太平间。这就是芝加哥的方式。但在具体情况下，我的意思是沿着芝加哥大道向西走，直到它与河流北支交汇的地方。我们休息一下后就到那里。
This special bonus episode of 99% invisible is brought to you by the 2024 Lexus GX and Sirius XM. The Lexus GX is at the apex of high end luxury and high end utility. Even though you can totally imagine the GX sitting in a corporate parking lot. Another passionate group found the GX and claimed it as this highly capable, reliable, modifiable, and luxurious off-road and overlanding vehicle. People ask, what is overlanding? And you'll ask 10 people and you'll have 10 different answers. Well, I'll give you my definition. It's a fancy word for sleeping out in the boonies in your car.
这期99%无形之物的特别加长版节目由2024款雷克萨斯GX和Sirius XM为您呈献。雷克萨斯GX是高端豪华与高端实用性的巅峰之作。尽管你完全可以想象GX停在公司停车场里。另一个充满热情的群体发现了GX，并将其宣称为这款功能强大、可靠、可改装且豪华的越野和长途旅行车辆。人们问，什么是长途越野（overlanding）？你问10个人会有10种不同的答案。好吧，我来给出我的定义。这是在荒郊野岭睡在车里的一个时髦词汇。
Getting off the grid and knowing that you have the Capability to go off the grid that is Eric Kavanaugh from Lexus We had a fun time geeking out about all the GX could do on all these different terrains Even though we were idling on a roof of a parking garage on Goose Island in the middle of Chicago One of the features that comes standard on the overtrail model is multi-train select features that comes standard on the Overtrail model is multi-train select. So you'll see here this now unlocks a variety of different settings to help you navigate those trains better. So if you wanted to go through sand or you may find yourself in deep snow or dirt, the entire system is now going to recalculate
摆脱日常束缚，并且知道你有能力去探索荒野，这是雷克萨斯的埃里克·卡纳瓦尔（Eric Kavanaugh）说的。我们很高兴地探讨了GX在所有这些不同地形上能做的事情，尽管我们当时正 idling（怠速停泊）在芝加哥市中心鹅岛（Goose Island）一个停车场的屋顶上。越野（Overtrail）版标配的功能之一是多地形选择功能。标配的功能之一是多地形选择。所以你会在这里看到，这现在解锁了各种不同的设置，以帮助你更好地应对这些地形。所以如果你想穿过沙地，或者你发现自己身处深雪或泥土中，整个系统现在将重新计算
and adjust the suspension acceleration brakes to make that the best experience. Now when you're in multi-train select, you then hit your panoramic view monitor and you're now seeing this bird's eye view. This is called the multi-train monitor. So this is an additional view where you're getting really full clear view of where you are, right? You might be, if you're overlanding on that trail, this may be a side of a cliff, right? Or this could be, this is in front of you, this may be a tree stump right here.
并调整悬挂、加速和刹车，以确保带来最佳体验。现在，当你处于多地形选择模式时，你接着按下全景监控器，你现在就能看到这个鸟瞰视角。这被称为多地形监视器。所以这是一个额外的视角，让你对你所处的位置有一个非常全面、清晰的视角，对吧？你可能，如果你在那条小路上长途越野，这可能是悬崖边，对吧？或者这可能是，这就在你面前，这可能是一个树桩。
So when I go out off-roading, overlanding, having visibility on your car is like the biggest thing you could ask for. And to that end, I have to mention my favorite feature, which I think exemplifies the 2024 Lexus GX. It's so simple and in true 99 PI fashion. It's something that is not fancy and could be totally overlooked. But it tells you something about all the thought that went into the GX. And that is the shape of the front hood. One of the things that frustrates me about the big thought that went into the GX. And that is the shape of the front hood. One of the things that frustrates me about the big car that I have that fits all the kids that Joy mostly drives
所以当我出去越野、长途旅行时，汽车的视野是你所能要求的最大事情。为此，我必须提到我最喜欢的功能，我认为它完美体现了2024款雷克萨斯GX。它是如此简单，并且具有真正的“99 PI”风格。它不是什么花哨的东西，完全可能会被忽视。但它告诉你很多关于为GX投入的心思。那就是前引擎盖的形状。关于为GX投入的大量心思，有一件事让我感到沮丧。那就是前引擎盖的形状。我开的那辆能装下所有孩子的大车，大部分是由乔伊（Joy）开的，
is I can't judge where the end of the hood is. It kind of slopes down and I end up thinking I'm way closer to whatever it is in front of me than I actually am. It's absurd. I think I'm two feet away from a parked car and I'm actually six feet away. But this new Lexus elegantly solved my problem.
让我烦恼的一点是，我无法判断引擎盖的尽头在哪里。它有点向下倾斜，我最后以为自己离前面的什么东西近得很，其实根本没有。这太荒谬了。我以为我离一辆停着的车只有两英尺，实际上我有六英尺远。但这款新款雷克萨斯优雅地解决了我的问题。
The hood vents there, you see how they're higher, the indentations up top. That is designed so that when you're off-roading that you have good reference of where the end of your vehicle is. And paying attention to that need and solving for that function made the whole vehicle more striking. That right there, it is part of the look. You can see it from the outside that gives it that very kind of modular, aggressive stance. It's not so rounded maybe where you might see
那里的引擎盖通风口，你看它们是如何更高的，顶部的凹痕。这是为了当你越野时，你能很好地参照车辆的尽头在哪里。关注这种需求并解决该功能使整车更引人注目。就在那里，它是外观的一部分。你可以从外部看到它，赋予它那种非常模块化、具有攻击性的姿态。它可能没有那么圆润，也许你在
in the current generation. So the design solves the problem that makes the GX more functional in more places, and that affects the look, and that look makes the GX stand out. It's all about design iteration and an open, ongoing conversation between Lexus designers and engineers and this specific, passionate customer base asking for things that a group of people in a room, no matter how smart or well-intentioned they might be, could never anticipate on their own. That is the Lexus GX.
当前一代中可以看到的那样。因此，该设计解决了使GX在更多地方更具功能性的问题，这影响了外观，而这种外观使GX脱颖而出。这一切都是关于设计迭代以及雷克萨斯设计师、工程师与这个特定的、热情的客户群之间开放、持续的对话，这个客户群提出了一个房间里的一群人——无论他们多么聪明或出于多么良好的意愿——永远无法靠自己预料到的需求。这就是雷克萨斯GX。
But when you're out there in the middle of nowhere, a capable, reliable vehicle isn't the only thing you need. You need entertainment. You need company. You need companionship. And when there is no cell signal to be found and no FM radio towers for hundreds of miles, you can still turn on Sirius XM satellite radio and hear the voice of Rachel Steele. My name is Rachel Steele and I am a DJ on two classic rock channels, classic vinylinyl, Channel 26, and Classic Rewind, Channel 25.
但当你身处荒郊野岭时，一辆能力出众、可靠的汽车并不是你唯一需要的。你需要娱乐。你需要公司。你需要陪伴。当方圆数百英里找不到手机信号，也没有调频广播电台时，你仍然可以打开Sirius XM卫星广播，听到雷切尔·斯蒂尔（Rachel Steele）的声音。我的名字叫雷切尔·斯蒂尔，我是两个经典摇滚频道的DJ，经典黑胶频道（Classic Vinyl），第26频道，以及经典回溯频道（Classic Rewind），第25频道。
Huge Classic Rock fan, huge Rock fan in general. So tell me, what is the difference between Classic Rewind and Classic Vinyl? So we consider the Classic Rock time period to be from the early 60s through the late 80s. So Classic Vinyl, we cover the early 60s through the early 70s, and then we pick it up with the mid 70s to the late 80s on Classic Rewind. Jared Polin Tell me, like, when you turn on Channel 25,
我是个超级经典摇滚迷，总的来说是个超级摇滚迷。那么告诉我，经典回溯和经典黑胶有什么区别？所以我们将经典摇滚时期定为从60年代初到80年代末。所以经典黑胶，我们涵盖了60年代初到70年代初，然后我们在经典回溯上从70年代中期到80年代末接续。贾里德·波林（Jared Polin）告诉我，比如，当你打开第25频道时，
what is the reward waiting for you? Tiana Kemp I think with Classic Vinyl and Classic Rewind both, you get the ability to classic rewind both, you get the ability to reminisce, especially going back to those early days and hearing songs that you grew up with. It's always comfort. I think I always try to reach the listeners in a comfortable way. In the car, I feel like I am a companion.
等待着你的奖励是什么呢？蒂娜·坎普（Tiana Kemp）我认为，通过“经典黑胶”（Classic Vinyl）和“经典回放”（Classic Rewind），你能够重温经典，特别是回到那些早期岁月，听到你伴随着长大的歌曲。这总是一种慰藉。我想我总是试图以一种舒适的方式接触听众。在车里，我觉得自己是一个陪伴者。
I think all DJs are a companion. And what we have in common is the music. So I love to be able to share stories and bring these artists to life. And I think the car is the perfect opportunity to do that. You know, people kick back and relax. And especially in a car as beautiful as the Lexus GX. I would love to kick back and relax
我认为所有的DJ都是陪伴者。而我们的共同点就是音乐。所以我喜欢能够分享故事并让这些艺术家重现生机。我认为汽车是做到这一点的绝佳机会。你知道的，人们会放松身心。特别是在像雷克萨斯GX这样漂亮的汽车里。我很想放松一下
and listen to music in a vehicle like that. To learn more about the GX, lexus.com slash GX. And with every purchase you'll get three months of SiriusXM free. The all new Lexus GX. Live up to it. And now me and Joy back out on the street in Chicago. So this is an office building in the old Montgomery Ward complex. It was designed by Manuro Yamasaki.
并在这样的汽车里听音乐。要了解更多关于GX的信息，请访问lexus.com slash GX。每次购买，您都将获得三个月的免费SiriusXM服务。全新雷克萨斯GX。不负所期。现在我和乔伊回到了芝加哥的街头。所以这是一座位于老蒙哥马利·沃德综合体的办公楼。它由山崎实（Manuro Yamasaki）设计。
And I have to admit, when I lived here, I rarely looked up at this building. It's a standard modern sort of cereal box with graph paper on it. It does have these notable like white concrete columns on the four corners. It makes it kind of a little more chunky. It's still sleek but chunky. And I pass it every day on my way home from work from WBC. I would walk past this over the river and then catch the blue line home to Logan Square. And part of the reason you can ignore it
我必须承认，当我住在这里时，我很少抬头看这栋建筑。它是一种标准的现代火柴盒式建筑，上面画着坐标纸。它在四个角上确实有这些显眼的白色混凝土柱。这让它看起来有点厚重。它依然线条流畅但又带着厚重感。我每天下班回家的路上都会经过它，从WBC下班。我会走过这条河，然后坐蓝线地铁回家去洛根广场。你能忽视它的部分原因是
is there's like you've seen, there's like so many cool buildings in Chicago. It's kind of hard to stand out as a skyscraper in Chicago. But regardless, even with this sort of blue-green tinted glass, it just didn't grab me. And then I took the Chicago Architecture Center's boat tour. And the docent told me why this building has those thick concrete corner supports. First, they open up the floor plan so that you can make your office as open an area as you want, because there's no internal walls that need to be there. But most importantly, to me anyway, was that the Montgomery Ward Company prided
就像你看到的，芝加哥有太多酷炫的建筑了。在芝加哥，作为一座摩天大楼要想脱颖而出其实有点难。但无论如何，即使有这种蓝绿色调的玻璃，它就是没能吸引我。然后我参加了芝加哥建筑中心的游船之旅。导游告诉我为什么这座建筑有那些厚实的混凝土角柱。首先，它们打开了平面布局，让你可以把办公室做成你想要的任何开放区域，因为不需要内墙。但对我来说最重要的是，蒙哥马利·沃德公司引以为傲的是
itself on having this sort of egalitarian hierarchy, and they didn't want executives fighting over who got a corner office. So they designed a building without any possibility of a corner office at all. It's now been converted into luxury condos and it's simply known as the Montgomery. And I bet the developers like hate those that coms with all their heart, you know, wishing they could sell a corner condo that doesn't exist. But that story makes me love this building. And so I think it's great. That story has stayed with me for years and I've taken the Chicago Architecture Boat Tour.
它拥有一种平等的等级制度，他们不希望高管们为谁能分到转角办公室而争吵。所以他们设计了一栋根本不可能有转角办公室的建筑。它现在已被改造成豪华公寓，被称为蒙哥马利大厦。我敢打赌，开发商恨透了这些柱子，恨不得能卖出一套根本不存在的转角公寓。但这个故事让我爱上了这座建筑。所以我认为这很棒。这个故事陪伴了我多年，我也参加了芝加哥建筑游船之旅。
You know, I've now five or six times we're going to do it tomorrow. It's really, really stunning. And because of that tour, I think of this as one of my favorite buildings. And keep in mind, this is a building I rarely even bothered to crane my neck to look at. I really did pass it daily. But I've learned to appreciate its aesthetics more as I retold that story again and again. And it's why I contend that story is the universal language of design, even more than aesthetics. Like, don't get me wrong, I love pretty things, but sometimes prejudice and bias and ignorance and taste get in the way of me loving a brilliant structure with a great story to tell.
你知道的，我已经去过五六次了，我们明天还要去。真的非常非常迷人。正是因为那次参观，我认为这是我最喜欢的建筑之一。请记住，这是一栋我以前甚至懒得抬头去看一眼的建筑。我确实每天都从它旁边走过。但当我一遍又一遍地重述那个故事时，我学会了更多地欣赏它的美学。这就是为什么我坚持认为故事是设计的通用语言，甚至比美学更重要。听着，别误会我，我喜欢美丽的事物，但有时偏见、无知和品味会阻碍我爱上一座拥有伟大故事的杰出建筑。
And that revelation led to 99% invisible. So this building is in many ways why I do what I do today. I love that. Yeah. So you haven't spent a lot of time here in Chicago. I haven't. I've only visited once before and I haven't really roamed around or explored. It's nice isn't it?
而这个启示催生了“99%无形”（99% Invisible）。所以这座建筑在很多方面解释了我今天为什么要做我所做的事。我喜欢这样。是的。所以你没有在芝加哥花太多时间。没有。我以前只来过一次，而且并没有真正四处闲逛或探索。这很不错，不是吗？
I'm excited to see more. I'm excited about that boat tour. Yes, the boat tour is the best. It really is. So you'll hear maybe somebody's tours again. Yeah, yeah. But it's, it's really worth it to be on the river looking at everything. Yeah. Anyway, well thanks for joining me in Chicago. Thanks for taking me. And thank you everybody for joining us in this special Chicago episode of 99% Invisible brought to
我很兴奋能看到更多。我很期待那个游船之旅。是的，游船之旅是最棒的。真的。所以你可能还会听到别人的游览。是的，是的。但是，在河上看着这一切真的很值得。无论如何，谢谢你陪我在芝加哥。谢谢你带我逛。也谢谢大家加入我们的99%无形特殊芝加哥分集，本节目由
you by the Lexus GX and SiriusXM. And thanks to Eric Kavanaugh, Rachel Steele, and Joy Usan for being my special guests. The new Lexus GX showcases how aesthetic appeal complements utility, proving luxury and capability can coexist. And when you throw Sirius XM in there, you have everything you need to be out in the farthest reaches while still being connected to a passionate community of music loving DJs, world class talkers, comedians and thinkers. To learn more about the GX and Sirius XM in Lexus vehicles, visit lexus.com.
雷克萨斯GX和SiriusXM为您呈现。感谢埃里克·卡纳瓦尔（Eric Kavanaugh）、雷切尔·斯蒂尔（Rachel Steele）和乔伊·乌桑（Joy Usan）作为我的特别嘉宾。全新雷克萨斯GX展示了美观如何与实用性相辅相成，证明了豪华与性能可以共存。当你在其中加入SiriusXM时，你就拥有了身处最偏远地区所需的一切，同时仍与热爱音乐的DJ、世界级的谈话节目主持人、喜剧演员和思想家组成的充满激情的社区保持联系。要了解有关雷克萨斯汽车中GX和SiriusXM的更多信息，请访问lexus.com。
The all-new Lexus GX. Live up to it. Throughout the episode, maybe you noticed me saying a few non-sequiturs, maybe some stuff that didn't make sense, but I'm hoping they made sense to at least some of you, because I wasn't just saying things, I was quoting things. There were five, yes, five Chicago movie quotes in this episode. If you think you can name all five movies, head to 99pi.org, go to this episode's show page and see how many you got right.
全新雷克萨斯GX。不负所期。在整集节目中，也许你注意到我说了一些风马牛不相及的话，也许有些内容毫无意义，但我希望它们对你们中的至少某些人来说是有意义的，因为我不仅仅是在随便说话，我是在引用台词。本集里有五个，是的，五个芝加哥电影的台词引用。如果你认为你能说出全部五部电影的名字，请前往99pi.org，访问本集的节目页面，看看你答对了多少。
While you're there, you can look at me posing with a fancy car and you can stream your first how many you got right. app. Go to 99pi.org to test your Chicago movie knowledge and subscribe to SiriusXM. 99% Invisible was reported and edited this week by me, Roman Mars, with production help from Isabelle Angel and Sarah Bake, mixed and sound designed by Dara Hirsch, music by Swan Real. Special thanks this week to McGrath Lexis of Chicago. Kathy too is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason De Leon, Vivian Le, LaShamma Dawn, Christopher Johnson, Martin Gonzalez, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriela Gladney, Kelly Prime, and Jacob Multanada-Madina. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
当你在那里的时候，你可以看到我和一辆豪华轿车的合影，并且你可以流式传输你的……看你答对了多少。应用程序。前往99pi.org测试你的芝加哥电影知识并订阅SiriusXM。本周的《99%无形》由我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）报道和剪辑，伊莎贝尔·安吉尔（Isabelle Angel）和莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）提供制作帮助，达拉·希尔什（Dara Hirsch）负责混音和声音设计，斯旺·雷尔（Swan Real）配乐。本周特别感谢芝加哥麦格拉思雷克萨斯（McGrath Lexus of Chicago）。凯西·图（Kathy too）是我们的执行制片人，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、拉沙马·唐（LaShamma Dawn）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriela Gladney）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）和雅各布·穆尔塔纳达-马迪纳（Jacob Multanada-Madina）。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful uptown Oakland, California. Our headquarters online is 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部现在位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部现在位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城。我们的在线总部是99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。